اصدرت السفاره الصينيه في كوريا الجنوبيه
اشعارا بتعليق اصدار التاشيرات في قصيره
الاجل للمواطنين الكوريين الجنوبيين الذين
يزورون الصين للعمل او السياحه او العلاج
الطبي او العبور او الشؤون الخاصه العامه
تاتي هذه الخطوه ردا على اجراءات الممثله
اتخذتها كوريا الجنوبيه التي وضعت في
الاونه الاخيره قيودا ومتطلبات اختبار
الفايروس لي زوار القادمين من البر
الرئيسي الصيني واوضح ان القيود المفروضه
على الوافدين من الصين اتخذت على اسس
علميه وزير خارجيه البلاد ناقشه مع نظيره
الصيني هاتفا قضايا شبه الجزيره الكوريه
واكد ان امتناع بيونغ عن مزيدا من
الاستفزازات
يصبوا في المصلحه المشتركه بين بيجين
للمتابعين ضميلي مدير مكتب الجزيره ناصر
عبد الحق ومن بلومبيان في كوريا
الجنوبيه او عفوا في سول في كوريا
الجنوبيه مراسل والجزيره محمد
البقالي مرحبا بكما ابدا معك ناصر عبد
الحق هل هذا القرار الذي اتخذته بيجين
ياتي في اطار رد الفعل المباشر في اطار
المعامله بالمثل ام له ابعد اخرى
نعم محمد حقيقه ياتي في هذا الاطار الرب
المثل حيث كانت الصين خلال الفتره الماضيه
قد اعلنت يعني بكل صراحه انها ستتخذ
اجراءات مماثله ضد البلدان التي اتخذت
اجراءات وقيود ضد المسافرين الصينيين
وبالتالي يعني هذا القرار الصيني ياتي بعد
يوم واحد من المكالمه الهاتفيه التي
اجراها وزير الخارجيه همم الصيني مع نظيره
الكوري الجنوبي حيث اعرب شينغ كونغ وزير
الخارجيه الصيني
لنظيره الكوري عن عن امله في انت تتخذ
كوريا الجنوبيه قراراتها في هذا الاطار
بشكل موضوعي همم وعلمي وبالتالي بعد يوم
من هذه المكالمه جاء القرار الصيني
بوقف اصدار التاشيرات للقادمين او
المسافرين من كوريا الجنوبيه باتجاه الصين
يذكر ان كوريا الجنوبيه كانت الوجهه
الاولى والاكثر ما يعني التذاكر تذاكر
السفر نحو كوريا الجنوبيه كانت الاكثر
مبيعا لدى الصينيين بعد رفع القيود
الصينيه همم الخاصه باجراءاتها تجاه او ضد
فيروس كورونا نعود الى المكالمه الهاتفيه
التي جرت بين الوزيرين همم هذه المكالمه
بالاضافه الى موضوع كورونا والاجراءات
تطرقت الى قضايا عده من بينها العلاقات
بين البلدين والتي سعى خلالها خلال هذه
المكالمه الوزيرين همم الى ذكر هذه
العلاقات والسبل تطويرها بناء على
القرارات التي اتخذها زعماء البلدين او
رئيس البلدين في هذا الاطار حيث تربط
كوريا الجنوبيه بالصين علاقات تجاريه
واقتصاديه كبيره وقال وزير الخارجيه بان
كوريا الجنوبيه هي جار مهم بالنسبه للصين
بالاضافه الى ذلك طبعا قضيه اييي الازمه
في شبه الجازوري الجزيره الكوريه كانت على
راس المحادثات بين الوزيرين حيث شهدت
المنطقه خلال الفتره الاخيره توبرا كبيرا
باطلاق كوريا الجنوبيه عده صواريخ
وقامت كوريا الجنوبيه على اثرها بالاعلان
بانها ستقوم بتطوير قدراتها الدفاعيه او
لرضع همم كوريا الشماليه من هذه من هذه
التجارب
محمد ولكن الصين ايضا تراقب عن كذب وباميه
كل هذه القضيه لانها تقع كل هذه التجارب
والمواجهه الثقافيه بالقرب من شواطئها في
بحر الصين الشرقي
الى محمد البقالي انا متعود عليك دائما في
فرنسا
اسم المنطقه اسمها يونج جانجري وهي في
كوريا الجنوبيه همم محمد سمعنا الى روايه
بيجينا نود ان نتعرف على همم هاذين
الخبرين من وجهه النظر الكوريه الجنوبيه
بالتاكيد المتعلق بالكورونا والمتعلق
بالاتصالات في بين الوزيرين
فبالنسبه هنا موضوع كورونا الموضوع يبدو
بالنسبه لكوريا
الجنوب مرتبط بقرار علمي وموضوعي وفقا
لتصريحات المسؤولين انهم قدره بان الوضع
الوباء في الصين يفرض بان يتم اتخاذ
اجراءات تقليديه على وصول المسافرين
القادمين من الصين وفي هذا اطار تم فرض
الحصول على اختبار سلبي من فايروس كورونا
منذ الخامس من هذا الشهر وكان الرد الصيني
عليه بتعليق التاشيرات على كل حال وهذا
يعني ان الامر على الارجح هذا سيتم حله
وفقا للوضعيه الوبائيه لان الصين اعلنت في
او على الاقل السفاره الصينيه هنا في
كوريا الجنوبيه اعلنت بان تقييم الموقف
سيتم وفقا للاجراءات التي ستتخدها مستقبلا
كوريا الجنوبيه الموضوع ربما الاكثر اهميه
هو موضوع التوتر الذي تعيش على ايقاعه
المنطقه همم حديث الحديث الذي جمع بين
وزيري الخارجيه الكوري الجنوبي وما بين
الوزير الخارجيه الصيني يصب ايضا في هذا
السياق في سياقات التهنئه ونحن نعلم بان
المنطقه تعرفها صعيدا منذ نهايه العام من
خلال اطلاق كوريا الشماليه والتي
بالمناسبه توجد خلفان اوجد هنا هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه حدوديه توجد ربما طبعا
الكاميرا لن تظهر الصوره بشكل واضح ولكنها
توجد في الجانب الاخر من الحدود كوريا
الجنوبيه كوريا الشماليه التي اطلقت
صواريخ باليسيا في نهايه السنه اطلقت ايضا
طائرات مسيره اخترقت المجال الجوي
لكوريا الجنوبيه وهو الذي اثار التوترا
كبيرا واثار غضبا هذا بالاضافه الى
التصعيد الكلام واللفظي في اللهجه بين
البلدين على امتداد هذه السنه المنصمه
2022 يجب الاشاره هنا الى انه في عام 2022
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه 70 صاروخا وهذا
الامر تعتبر كوريا الجنوبيه نفسها من غنيه
به بشكل مباشر وتهديدا كبيرا لها هذه هذه
المحادثه الهاتفيه ما بين وزيريه الخارجيه
تاتي في اطار البحث عن سمول التهدئه
معرفه بان الصين هي فاعل رئيسي في المنطقه
وفي هذا الصراع ايضا كوريا الجنوبيه هي في
نهايه المطاف صحيح هي حليف كبير للولايات
المتحده ولكنها لا تريد ان تضع كل بيضها
في سله الولايات المتحده في الفعل هناك
28,000 جندي امريكي في صول هناك ايضا
مناورات مشتركه بين الولايات المتحده وبين
كوريا الجنوبيه ولكن الصول تعرف بان لا
يمكنها اغضاب جارها الكبير الصين ثم ان
علاقاتها الاقتصاديه كبيره مع الصين 40%
او 40% من الصادرات الكوريه الجنوبيه تتجه
الى الصين ثم 25% من المبادلات التجاريه
لكوريا الجنوبيه مع الصين اقتصاديا اشكرك
عسكريا تحاول كوريا الجنوبيه ان تبحث عن
توازن بين علاقتهم على الولايات المتحده
ومع الصين وفي هذا السياق تاتي هذه
المكالمه من يونج
زي في كوريا الجنوبيه مراسل الجزيره محمد
البقالي اشكرك كما اشكر ناصر عبد الحق
مدير مكتب الجزيره كان معنا من بيجين